Every missile taken down.
Yes.
Gunfire means lives saved.
Here with a German short range captured
or hear one missile
taken down with a machine gun
precursory on this blue train.
It's a pity that I didn't
shoot down three.
It's a shame that two got through
They hit civilian targets
or critical infrastructure
facilities and people walk there.
Fuck yeah.
We call in a reporter.
So you these are Ukrainian drone hunters.
And day and night
they scan the skies, eyes
in the backs of their heads,
their machine gun
loaded onto an armored vehicle.
Trading warmth, fragility
within those minutes.
The trajectories of the missiles
and drones
are constantly changing,
which means that stationary units
were not enough.
So we created mobile ones.
Most nights,
this is what the skies above Ukraine look
and sound like.
And more than a year into the war,
all that Western equipment is helping.
On Wednesday night, over 90 missiles
and HRT drones were detected.
Of those more than 30 missiles
and four charges were intercepted,
says the Ukrainian military
here in the frontline town of Kupang.
So you can see what more than a year
of heavy artillery
and mortar fire have done.
It was again the case on Wednesday night.
There's not much air defense
can do about that.
On the whole,
what the Ukrainian military says
is that with Western
help, its air
defense systems
have actually been remarkably efficient.
And from the very start of the invasion,
if sure,
if this hadn't happened,
we would probably not be talking to now
and there would be no such countries.
Ukraine,
thanks to the Air Force,
we really managed
to hold the keys to the sky.
This is a rare close up
look at Iran's technology of death.
A Shanghai drone
relatively intact
for having been fished
out of the Black Sea at its head.
It would have carried 50 kilograms
worth of explosives.
This is what 20 kilograms looks like
And this is what
that looks like on the ground.
Part of Russia's
devastating war of attrition
with civilian casualties
on most nights Way beyond the front lines
of the east
and air
and beyond the direct casualties
that I mentioned there,
there are, in fact, of course,
all the indirect casualties.
We're only just getting power
restored here.
To the wider hockey region.
In Hockey City,
there hasn't been power
since those overnight strikes
from Wednesday to Thursday.
That means people,
no electricity,
no water, nothing to wash and clean with
for all that time.
And that's part of this war of attrition,
Erin.
So, Melissa,
thank you very much there
and reporting all of that.
I want to bring in now the former U.S.
ambassador to Russia, John Sullivan.
And Ambassador.
You know,
you saw there,
Melissa, standing with that that drone
and the payload of the drone
as she was
showing you sort of what,
half of the payload would look like.
But we're talking about £110.
That's the payload there
in the context of the reporting here
that Ukraine is saying
that Russia has used 40% of its highest
and missiles,
the Kinzel Hypersonic
missiles,
six in yesterday's attack alone.
Why would Putin use
so many of his best missiles
in one attack at this point?
Well, thanks, Daryn.
Good to be with you.
When they use a missile
like the Kinsale,
which can't be intercepted
by the Ukrainians,
that means they
definitely want to hit the target
they're aiming at.
They don't want to run a risk that
the missile that's heading for
that target is going to be intercepted.
The tradeoff they make
is that it's it's
a very expensive
and sophisticated weapons system,
which is why the Ukrainians
can intercept it.
Why in yesterday's attack,
this was payback for what?
What happened in Russia last week
when elements crossed the border
from Ukraine into Russia
and then what's an attack?
So today, Prigozhin,
the Wagner Group
chief, of course, announced
he's opening these
these new recruitment centers
across Russia,
dozens of them
eight in Moscow alone,
which, of course,
as I mentioned, is home
to Russia's elite.
The wealthier
citizens really has not sent
many soldiers to the front lines,
although
someone was telling me
the other day
that sometimes
now you go down in the subways
and there are there
people waiting to
to talk to men and to bring them
to to mobilize them.
Does this move the needle
at all,
this sort of recruiting,
these recruitment centers?
In my opinion, absolutely not.
This move indicates that
for Ghosn's prior recruitment efforts
in another area,
the Russian prisons
have been closed off to him.
Russian men know
if they wanted to volunteer
for their Viognier.
They already opened a headquarters
in Saint Petersburg.
People know how to volunteer
for five year.
This is more publicity for for Prigozhin.
He's making these types of statements
every day.
He's, like,
existentially threatened in any way.
I mean,
I know
there's this ongoing fight between him
and the regular military, but,
you know,
he's saying he has no ammo,
can't get in touch with anybody.
Nobody will take his place.
Is. Is. Yeah, go ahead.
You call the minister of defense
and the chief of the general staff.
Traitors.
I I'm not surprised they will.
No one will take his calls
in the Russian military establishment.
So earlier this week,
I spoke with a Russian journalist,
and he had some really strong reporting.
Exclusive
look at Putin's lavish life
with his reputed
girlfriend, the former Russian Olympic
gold medalist Elena Kabila
at Roman Maidan and is the reporter.
And he shared these pictures
of reportedly of Putin's home.
He said these are the
that's the exterior in Val Day.
And he also had
the interiors decked out
in gold, all sorts of different rooms.
And he was showing us all of this.
Now, Kabila's mansions
about half a mile away.
If this is the way Putin lives
and we understand
that he may still be spending
a lot of time there.
Do you think Putin's lifestyle
has been affected by the war or not?
Ambassador?
Well, I mean, from what
we have
seen, his lifestyle
has been affected
in the following sense, Erin.
He can't travel by air anywhere close
to in southwestern Russia
in getting to Sochi, for example,
one of his most favorite places to go.
He can't travel there by air.
He's now traveling more by train.
He's concerned about his own safety.
As for the economic impacts,
if the question is more about
supporting his lavish lifestyle,
I don't think that's as much of a concern
as concerns about his own safety,
concerns about his own safety.
But amazing on that.
Just on that
issue of the actual lifestyle itself.
With all of the sanctions we hear about.
You think that that would be
very untouched at this point?
I would think so.
I mean,
if money is going to go to anybody
in that system, it's
going to the guy at the top.
And he's got plenty of it.
And the Russian Russian people
themselves are well aware of this.
They've seen
through Navalny's organization the
you know, the billion dollar palace.
He's got Sochi.
So this isn't a surprise
to anyone either.
But it's very interesting
to see the photographs you referred to
and to see it actually documented.
Yeah, it certainly it certainly is.
There's some great reporting by Mr.
Bannon and his team.
All right.
Thank you so much, Ambassador Sullivan.
I appreciate your time.